einmal um zuzuordnen von wo sie uns
geradezu schalten frau sue karibik sie
stehen auf der terrasse oder auf dem
balkon eines größeren hauses in tel aviv
wir haben einmal das kenntlich gemacht
auf der karte wo ungefähr sich das
befindet um unsere zuschauer mitzunehmen
und ganz in der nähe hat in den
vergangenen tagen auch raketeneinschläge
gegeben das heißt auch sie haben die
erfahrung natürlich gemacht mit
raketenalarm und eben dann auch
einschlägen ein video das sie uns
geschickt haben das stammt von wan frau
so karibik schreiben was man da sieht
sie sehen hier den direkten einschlag
einer rakete wahrscheinlich eine
asiatische 250 rakete in einem parkhaus
in rama cent pro minute vor sachschaden
alle alle menschen waren zu dem
zeitpunkt bereits im bunker ich war zu
dem zeitpunkt war natürlich hier
aufgrund der unmittelbaren nähe ein sehr
lauter knall
es war mir ganz klar dass das etwas ist
was eine andere art explosion also nicht
nur deren sohn der die hamas raketen
abschießt das sind immer so dumm für
zwar laut aber dunklen als er aus der
ferne wenn man das mal so unmittelbar
dass ich mich in der tat so auf meine
zwei schlafenden war nicht mehr schlafen
kinder geworfen habe in der bodybuilder
das erleben darf ich fragen wie sie das
erleben ihre kinder schauen wir das
erste mal während dem 2014 gaza krieg
war meine kleine tochter ein halbes jahr
und und hat die meisten nächte in der
zeit im bunker verbracht und damals war
es einfach weil ich sie einfach hin
tragen konnte uns die hat natürlich ein
sechs monate altes kind nichts
mitbekommen
es ist jetzt herzzerreißend wirklich
reisen zu sehen wie diese glücklichen
kinder die normalerweise nur strahlen
und witze machen
verängstigt sind sich nicht trauen aus
dem bunker rauszukommen
die betten wie mich an wir schlafen
schon seit einer woche in bunker ich
kann mir nicht eine sekunde dort alleine
in den ersten tagen war ich alleine mit
ihnen weil mein mann in die reserve
einbezogen wurde
und sie fürchten sich so wenn ich auch
nur eine minute rausgehe und den start
zu gehen oder sonst wo ein glas wasser
zu holen
das heißt und das sind nicht natürlich
nicht nur meine kinder da sind alle
kinder die diesen raketen terror
ausgesetzt sind und was mir wirklich das
herz zerbricht obwohl es mir davor schon
bewusst war aber nie so stark wie jetzt
wo ich sehe wie meine kinder darunter
leiden
das sind die kinder im süden ich
schreibe diesen raketentyp tag zu tag
ausgesetzt sind und sprechen von denen
kamaz raketen die meist eben nicht in
den medien erscheinen die einfach tag zu
tag tröpfeln und tröpfeln und die seele
und die psyche dieser kinder und
gesandte familientag zerstören das sind
kinder die am 15 sekunden zeit um sich
in sicherheit zu bringen in den bunker
wenn die sirene los geht
wir sind kinder die duschen nicht normal
die gehen nicht normal die toilette die
es noch nicht normal weil sie ständig
mit dieser terror angst leben
um diese angst um ihr eigenes leben weil
es einfach ständig passiert dass man es
nicht schafft in den bunker und das ist
ein direkter anschlag gibt und wir haben
alleine jetzt in den letzten tagen durch
diese 3000 raketen der hamas elf
todesopfer und das ist nur todes nur elf
sind und damit beende ich meine antwort
ist ein immenses brille durch diese
malware um den wir haben und es ist auch
kein zug weil es ist wirklich dieser
geniale innovationsgeist der an diesem
um diese abwehr rakete gearbeitet hat
und dafür sorgt dass hier nacht
einigermaßen einigermaßen sicher
schlafen können und es eben nur elf
todesopfer und kein nation nationales
blutbad geworden ist was die kammer sie
anrichtet